I understand the disaster slow motion
train wreck that is the sport of
football I'm obsessed Now Blake Lively's
having fun with hubby's fever pitch she
really does just show me how to be
better in almost every way she was
showing a nervous Ryan on the Jumbotron
as the Deadpool star watched a wrexham
match over the weekend Blake shares with
her fans on Instagram I bought ESPN plus
today just to watch my husband
experience crippling anxiety live worth
it it's impossible not to get along with
him of course Ryan's got more at stake
than most people know where to find us
Ryan's a team co-owner with It's Always
Sunny Star Rob mcelhaney how did you
explain this to your wife I'm not that
dumb Kevin I promise you I would consult
my wife before putting pants on
um she's as obsessed as I am she's
already like looking at the schedule
throughout the year wondering which
matches she can attend she was like I
get it it's a good evening yeah it's
like I get the answer I'm I'm now as
obsessed if not more than you are with
this club and this community and this
town and everything it represents and
where where it can go and there is a
version of the story uh where we are
villains
where it does my usual starts usually
the story in my head Ryan and Rob's
unlikely purchase of the Welsh football
club was chronicled on the docu-series
welcome to wrexham I do not like losing
yeah
this is true
another objective getting support from
the royal family yeah that's Ryan and
Rob last month chatting up the king and
queen consort Camilla it'll be a Ryan
sized hole in the wall it would appear
that I'm short
the truth is that I I'm not short it's
that you're a mutant you two are
spitting images of each other do you see
it oh oh they look at
[Music]
it guys please tell me he does not also
look like Ryan wait hold on can you hand
me that for a second
y'all you and your cheekbones I mean you
and Ryan oh yeah there we go there it is
right back to Ryan and Blake the
couple's got plenty to celebrate like
their 10-year wedding anniversary in
Hollywood years that's like 145 years
we've been together I think so how do
you guys do it yeah well we like each
other that's important you know so it's
a good foundation for any relationship
and last year Blake hit us with another
baby bump reveal on the red carpet for
four years old how excited are you and
Blake I'm we're very excited you know uh
we'd have to be you know you'd have to
be a to do this four times if he
didn't like it well rexham ended up in a
draw over the weekend but these two call
themselves winners in the Game of Love
um I'm paired up with my best friend and
that's I know rob you and Caitlin are
the same way it's it's you know when
that happens you you recognize how
unbelievably Lucky You Are
foreign